EA FRONT OF T
NSWEON
CONTACTS THAT  KEY
ABOUTUR
E ACCORDTOCH WAS O
CNN, SHE THAT SHE NEVER
SPOKE TO HER HUSBANDBO
DETAILS OF HER VOLTE
ION TIES OR ANHALLENGES TO THE
ON. TOLD THE COMMITTEE
THAT SHE STIS THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
WON NAMED GINNOMAS. ENT TRP AL T
DOW GINNI THOMAS?A
THE WIFEA GREAT
CLARENCE THOMAS, FOR HERSTRENGTH
LIKETHRE ECTENDIDN'T WILT UNDERE
WEAK PEOD UP
IT STR ME, THIS JUSTS  HEADACHEE
>> SEV TO ARGUE THAT THE C OT A
DAY RE NEW TER
TO OPE ABBY.
YOU HAVE GINNIMA
DENIES THAT THTION WASFAN SHOUL
ALREADY BEEN IE SPACCAST WHETHE
SUGGESTED THERMI FUD
HE THINKS STATE LEGISLATURES R
INFLUENCING HER.EY HAVE BOTHLY
ABOUT THES.ISE, AS YOU SAY,
ABCOURT'S
AB BE FAIR A
P NUMBERS AREE JUSTICES AREEEI
LEGITIMACY OF THESTIONL IN THE
ANRSED
>> THE CONFLUENCE OF
THE APOV RATINGS FORHE
COURT WENT FROM  IN
2000, JUSTDO YOUHA
IT'S 47%TH OL
THOSEED.
ADG COAL RUST INTITUTIONS HAS BN
YEANBUT THE LEVET T TH-- A O
THAT CAME AFTER THE S ON, TOO.FE
EN SAY THEY DO NOT COURT, THEG
L
M H.
T  --
DEATTHAT'SLY Y ARIN
RECEDENCE.
LISG
E RESPONDING TO
>> THEY ARE.
O SAY,HEY Y BACK PRECEDENT, THEE
AND E DOING
OF URGENCYWHAT'S HAPPENEIS, THF
JUSTHAS LE'S ION WITH THE
OUCYALO  FGAVE A STATEME"THE LL
EXPR
DECRITICIZE OU
REASONING AS THEY SEBUHAIS BECO
ILLEGITIMATUTIONTIONING OUR INTT
HE WASNDINTO LINE.
COURT ISN'IKCOURT,UESTIONE
IF IT' WAYS.W THAT THE SIX
CONSERVATIVEER MAJORITY, EVERYOA
THE THREE JUSTICES ON THE LEFT
ABOUT  H
> THE IC PUBLIC ISN'T
BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE YOUR  ARE
THIS
H
SU
THE COURT RELEASED THIS PHOT
ON
FOUR WOMEN.
WOMAN OTHNOWITINA WOMANA
THE KAGAN IAS RIGHT ABOUT THA>.
COURT IN A V TE.OMENSEAT